Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch and
I'm musician-in-residence
at Yale University's
Fortunoff Video Archive for Holocaust
Testimonies.
This video series is
designed as a companion
to our album Where Is Our Homeland, which
is the first volume in the archives ongoing
effort to present songs and poems
performed by survivors in testimonies given
to the Fortunoff Archive over the last
forty years.
You can learn more about the project on the
Archive's website,
songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies,
Volume One was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble, featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua Camp
on the accordion, keyboards and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass, and myself
on woodwinds.
The songs in this
collection differ vastly in
terms of style, social and historical
background, language,
and many other aspects,
but collectively they
create a multidimensional
picture of Jewish life before and
during World War II.
Irene S. was born in 1925
in Berezhany, or Brzezany, Galicia,
now Ukraine, and was raised in Grudziadz,
Poland.
She was a survivor of the Bialystok ghetto
and several concentration camps, including
Majdanek, Treblinka and Auschwitz.
Irene was a slave laborer in Germany
and was liberated by the Americans in
Kaunitz.
By the time the war broke out,
Irene already was an
accomplished singer and
songwriter.
In her testimony, she
recalls singing existing
songs and composing new ones together
with her young fellow prisoners from Poland
and the Soviet Union.
The poem "Sakhki,
Sakhki," otherwise known as
"Ani Ma'amin," "I Believe," was
written by the poet, translator, physician
and writer Shaul Tchernichovsky in
Odessa, Ukraine, then Russian Empire,
in 1892.
Tchernichovsky was
born in Ukraine to a modern
religious family, and studied languages
in Odessa, where he became involved in
Zionist activities.
Tchernichovsky served
as a doctor in the Russian
army during World War I, and then
pursuing his dream, he repatriated
or emigrated to the land of Israel
to, then Palestine in 1931.
"I Believe" is one of
Tchernichovsky’s very early
poems, permeated by idealistic feelings.
The young poet unites
the ideals of liberty,
fraternity, peace, and Zionist ideals,
the Jewish people's hope and aspiration to
freely live in their ancestral land,
the land of Israel.
It is really moving and symbolic
how all these ideals
strongly resonated with the
feelings of the young inmates at
the ghettos and camps among which was
Irene. The songs like this helped them
survive and make it to the Liberation Day.
Ki od nafshi dror sho'efet--
if there was still freedom to my soul.
Because my soul still longs for freedom
I have not sold it for a golden calf.
Because I still believe in humanity
And in its spirit, a strong spirit.
Laugh, laugh at these dreams –
This is me, the dreamer, speaking
Laugh because I still believe in humanity,
Because I still believe in you.
Because my soul still longs for freedom,
I have not sold it for a golden calf.
Because I still believe in humanity
And in its spirit, a strong spirit.
This spirit will cast off
the shackles of falsehood,
And will be uplifted.
No worker shall die of hunger;
Freedom for the soul, bread for the poor.
In her testimony, Irene recalls
that while being
transported from the Bialystok
ghetto to an unknown destination,
she and other young people in the cattle
car began singing.
They sang, as she says, patriotic
songs, Zionist songs.
We were singing ourselves to go to
die, she says.
One of these songs whose melodies she wrote
herself was in Russian because
she says the boy who wrote the words
didn't know any Yiddish.
They did not sing for long because
the guards on the train shouted at them
to stop and fired into the cattle car,
wounding Irene and killing one
of the lads.
The transport passed by the extermination
camp, Treblinka.
And she remembers seeing vast fields
covered with ashes and bones.
But they went on to Lublin and she
subsequently was taken to the nearby
concentration and extermination camp
Majdanek.
Yet Irene also remembers that the young
men and women in the cattle car sang
another song and she beautifully
sings a few verses of it.
The song is known as "Sakhki, Sakhki,"
although its original name is "I Believe,"
"Ani Ma'amin." Irene
does not mention the name of the song
and erroneously attributed to
Hayim Nahman Bialik.
In fact, it is based on a poem
written by Shaul Tchernichovsky, another
important Jewish Zionist poet from
Ukraine who, like Bialik,
ended up living in Palestine.
Tchernichovsky was
born in a small Ukrainian
village in 1875
and wrote "Sakhki, Sakhki" in 1894,
when he was merely 19 years old.
At the time, he was living in Odessa
and already knew both Russian and Hebrew.
He subsequently also learned German,
English and French, as well as
ancient Greek and Latin.
A man of great talent and energy, he
studied medicine at the Universities of
Heidelberg, Lausanne and Kiev.
While studying at
Heidelberg, Tchernichovsky
also married the anarchist Russian
aristocrat Melania Karlovna,
a Christian of Polish, German
and Ukrainian descent.
Their marriage lasted until his death
in 1943.
Tchernichovsky served as a military doctor
in the Russian army in World War I
and emigrated with his wife and daughter to
Palestine in 1931.
He spent the last years of his life,
having contracted leukemia, in the
Greek patriarchs' residence in
San Simon in Jerusalem, along
with his wife, who had become a devout
Orthodox Christian.
Tchernichovsky is
remembered as one of the most
influential poets of his generation,
and his works betray the influence
of his Jewish heritage, his love
for biblical figures and the impact
of world literature.
"Sakhki Sakhki," which was included
in Tchernichovsky's first poetry collection
published in 1898, combines
a youthful belief in humanism, socialism,
the fraternity of nations, friendship,
and Zionism.
It was very popular among the Zionist
socialist youth of Irene's generation,
and it is no wonder that she
and her friends sang it in
their transport to hell.
My own mother, who was just a
year older than Irene, also
loved that poem, and I still recall
her singing it in my childhood.
But the song has remained very popular,
not least in Israel, and it is still
sung in youth movements, public
events, and social gatherings, and
has been performed by an array of popular
singers.
There are several
other interesting twists to
the story of "Sakhki, Sakhki," whose
original title, "Ani Ma'amin,"
refers to a pronouncement in the Jewish
prayer book, Siddur, based
on the writings of Maimonides,
which expresses the
thirteen main principles
of Jewish faith.
The words of Ani Ma'amin were made
into a popular Hasidic tune.
The well-known cantor, Azriel Fastag,
is said to have sung this Hasidic tune
on the train to Treblinka, where he was
murdered.
But unlike this Hasidic tune, the melody
of "Sakhki, Sakhki"
sounds distinctly Russian.
Officially, the composer of this song
is said to have been Tuvia Shlonsky,
a Zionist from a Hasidic family
in Ukraine, and the father
of the influential Hebrew poet, editor,
and translator Avraham Shlonsky,
one of my own father's early mentors,
when he began his own literary career.
It is, however, quite likely that
the tune of "Sakhki, Sakhki" originated
in a Russian folk song from the Don region.
One indication of that is that the very
same melody was used for another song
written by Rabbi Avrahom Eliyahu Kaplan,
a major Orthodox figure from Lithuania,
which he wrote as a 17 year old lad.
The song, which expresses the spiritual
torment of a young soul and
its longing for God is officially titled
"Prayer," "Tfila." But it
is known and sung to this day under
the name "The Sun Has Set,"
"Shak'a Chama." Since it
is unlikely the Rabbi Kaplan also
wrote the tune, we can assume
that it was put to music using
the same popular Russian tune that
was used for "Sakhki, Sakhki,"
a Russian song that served
to animate both a Hasidic longing
for God, and a Zionist Socialist
longing for equality, fraternity,
and a new Jewish generation in Eretz
Israel.
One can find a beautiful performance
of "The Sun Has Set" by the Hasidic
singer Abish Brodt on YouTube.
The popularity of
"Sakhki, Sakhki" in Israel
to this day found another remarkable
expression in 2004
during a discussion in the Israeli
Knesset on the collective rights of,
of the Arab population in Israel.
At one point in the lengthy debate, the
Arab member of Knesset, Mohammad Barakeh,
proposed the Tchernichovsky "Sakhki,
Sakhki" would be a more appropriate
national anthem than the current one,
which speaks primarily about the
longing of Jews to Zion.
The proposal was rejected,
but it is a tantalizing
idea.
Perhaps one day Tchernichovsky's verse,
"For my soul still longs for freedom/I
have not sold it to the Golden Calf/
For I have still faith in humanity/And
in its spirit, fierce and
bold," sung by Jewish youth
on the way to Treblinka, will still
become the national anthem of
both Jews and Palestinians
in the state of Israel.